>> Greg: HELP FIGHT STRESS OF
UPCOMING FINALS, COLLEGES ARE
USING THERAPY LLAMAS.
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH FLORIDA AND
RADFORD UNIVERSITY TRUCKING IN
THIS IS GREAT FOR THE STUDENTS,
POOR THINGS.
WHAT ABOUT THE LAMAS WILL HAVE
TO ABSORB THE NOXIOUS, ANNOYING
ANGST OF FRAGILE IDLERS AS THEY
MOAN ABOUT THEIR INSULATED
EXISTENCE AND PERHAPS THE
EASIEST PHASE OF THEIR COMFY
LIVES.
SOME STUDIES SHOW PETS LOWER
STRESS BUT WHAT ABOUT THE STRESS
OF THE PET?
RUNNING THEIR BONY, STINKY
FINGERS THROUGH YOUR GORGEOUS
VERB.
IMAGINE A POOR BUNNY.
THEY ARE USING BUNNIES TOO,
FORCED TO SIT ON THE LAP OF THE
INTERFERING WITH HER SOCIAL
JUSTICE PUPPETRY THEATER.
I WOULD HURL MYSELF INTO
TRAFFIC.
FARMING -- BEFORE BECOMING A
STRESS.
WHEN WILL THIS END?
HOW WILL THEY HANDLE THE REAL
WORLD?
WILL LLAMAS ACCOMPANY YOU TO A
♪ ♪
MY STRESS LEVELS HAVE PLUMMETED.
THANKS, LORENZO.
>> Kimberly: IS IT A REAL
BLOCK?
>> Greg: IT IS.
NEUROTIC KIDS.
>> Kimberly: DON'T THEY SPIT
VICIOUSLY AT YOU?
IF YOU GET TOO CLOSE.
>> Greg: YOU GO THERE, YOU
LICENSE AND IT IS LLAMA --   -NE
LICENSE AND IT IS LLAMA --   -ND
LICENSE AND IT IS LLAMA --   -N.
>> Dana: I HAD A VERY
DIFFERENT COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
>> Greg: I HAD NO DOES.
YOU MEMBER THOSE PILLS?
>> Juan: YOU HAD SPEED.
>> Dana: I NEVER TRIED ONE OF
THOSE.
I WAS TOO AFRAID.
>> Jesse: I'M SURPRISED THAT
FRATERNITIES HAVEN'T STOLEN THE
LAMAS AND NONDRINKING.
>> Juan: WHY DO YOU BEAT UP
COLLEGE STUDENTS?
>> Greg: I DON'T BEAT THEM UP.
I AM NOT ALLOWED ON CAMPUSES.
>> Juan: BY COURT ORDER.
>> Greg: MOST COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE NOW BECOMING MORE
CONSERVATIVE, MORE LIBERTARIAN
BECAUSE THEY ARE REBELLING
AGAINST THE SOCIAL JUSTICE --
THEY ARE THE NEW REBELS.
>> Juan: WHERE DID YOU GO TO
COLLEGE?
>> Greg: I WENT TO BERKELEY.
>> Juan: MR. LEFT-WING.
>> Kimberly: THEY CAME TO
UC DAVIS.
WE USED TO BE NORMAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: EVEN TO GET INTO
BERKELEY, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
REALLY GOOD.
>> Juan: WHY ARE YOU MAKING
THEM INTO SNOWFLAKES?
>> Greg: I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING.
YOU KNOW THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
NEEDS LLAMAS.
YOU NEED TO PET.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S FINE.
LET THEM HAVE THE PETS.
>> Jesse: I AM HAVING A LLAMA
ON MY SHOW NEXT WEEK.
WE'RE GOING TO TALK TO A LLAMA
PROFESSOR.
>> Kimberly: HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO GET A JOB IN THE FUTURE IF
YOU ARE HANGING OUT WITH LLAMAS?
YOU HAVE SPIT ALL OVER YOUR